[Music]
and coping mechanism news got a lot of
those way left interesting way different
are than submitted by 10 to the 101
first are we gonna grande reveals she's
been using alcohol to cope with her
problems baby she's had an interesting
year she's got a ruffian interesting
month know why she's too much in the
spotlight you got to step away from that
[ __ ] dude
all that scrutiny and [ __ ] dude she
can't help her daughter never give up
huh I'm telling her to give up okay I
can't give up millions of dollars well
that's the thing so apparently she says
she's never consumed more alcohol than
Walt grieving Mac Miller's death the
Pete Davidson split oh he died for a
second oh [ __ ] and then being cooled by
the preacher chief of preachers who's on
stage during a [ __ ] terrorist attack
yeah that's been a bit of a year you can
see that [ __ ] during I read the frame in
the funeral it's one preacher you're
trying to like touch continue with the
elbow again oh you did a great job and
everyone was kind of like wait around
her wait kind of close in the name of
Jesus
well it was his hand wasn't on accident
City but it was pretty [ __ ] close like
this yeah it's [ __ ] like it's and then
weird and then he reinforced it did she
ever say like I felt him touch my titty
she was like you know we're cool like
it's just yeah what you guys proceeded
yeah if anything like people were more
grossed out by it than what she ever
said but it was definitely uncomfortable
to watch hell yeah this is a pretty dark
quote that you gotta hear this so an
interview with billboard released
Wednesday ariana grande revealed that
she's never consumed more alcohol than
she has in the past month she says I am
champagne let her finish the 25 year old
singer said you know how people say
we're 60% water I'm sixty percent pink
Veuve Clicquot oh damn okay she's making
so much
[ __ ] I guess it's like is that like some
expensive [ __ ] never heard of it oh you
think it's a brand deal what if it's a
brand deal imagine if she's only on
alcohol it's pretty good
like not coconut but that's not what
she's saying that she's doing really I
feel what is she saying no no I'm saying
like that's just what she said I think
it's pretty clear she's saying that
she's 60% champagne bro she's had a
rough year she's dead but she's missing
out the coke farm Sam that's max no I
mean everybody on our David is on coke
well he got some big-ass feet yeah well
you got a pickle dick apparently yeah
you ain't heard no I heard that's that's
where the phrase big dick energy kind of
stems from because from his big dick
from her talking about is how big his
dick is yeah did she say it or she
tweeted it right she tweeted like quote
retweeted and said something about big
dick energy I'm out don't quote me on
that don't quote me on her quote I'm
warning you she said it she absolutely
said it damn Davison's that won't the
big bags under his eyes yeah and now
he's bleached hair now
kind of like Ellen yeah okay with Middle
Eastern descent I did a couple things
while I was in nicely - oh really it'd
be nice when they brought it not easy
he's a good dude he was he was a fan
actually came up to me like when we were
first started shooting with a man I used
to watching videos I was like thanks bro
[ __ ] ariana grande wrote your love
when that [ __ ] happens
hey I used to watch you all the time and
I'm like I'm still doing things then why
take a picture of me now right you
should have to put him back then no I
don't know picture today but then like I
didn't meet you then hey Steve you used
to make really good stuff man
I know I might oh look a mother you'll
be like well to me specifically I
recently just had like a memory
situation out of college and a man
remember back in the Royal pizzas clean
days I'm like yeah those are still at
the end of my video this morning this
guy was like a man you don't post JK
news anymore and I'm like what are you
talking about bro I'm about to go film
it right now but I saw an episode where
you weren't there and you're like dude
what we post for a days but you know I
started doing this thing but I don't do
it anymore because it makes them really
uncomfortable so they'll be like yo May
I love yourself what did I post
and it says your pigs [ __ ] fate yeah
my [ __ ] relaxed house I wouldn't post
a month ago I like your stuff well yeah
I started forgiving people because I
remember I like I love the Wayans
brothers but I wasn't watching the
Wayans brothers they let their let their
like their last season you know saying
so I was like hmm
maybe I can forgive are you saying
you're on your last season right now
dude absolutely not I'm just saying I've
been doing this [ __ ] for a long time you
know yeah but think about all the videos
you'd have to watch of Tim to get caught
up yeah it's a lot insane dude I know
nobody's that big a fan not even his own
parent but Tim only appalled that once a
month night I'll have you know though I
do know a Fed that knows every aspect of
everybody's lives who that kid at the
fight Jim did you meet him a fight Jim
knows everything about Casey's life
actually met Casey and TIFF at when they
were shooting a music video that he
remembered every little detail of it
he knows [ __ ] about my life that I
forgot about but what and Chris it's
like you know when you talk about stuff
that happens during the day of when I do
these vlogs and I just do it because
it's a funny story then I move on from
it but he'll remember every [ __ ]
detail dude it's unreal mega fan and
they don't kick my ass in the gym that's
where I met Trish Paytas was I was on a
Shane Dawson music video and she was
just like a fan of hits and she was
there and she was like an extra in it
yeah that's how she started just coming
up doing like low sit here and there I'm
not crazy and she's Lee
she was always nice I don't even know
who this is Trisha Paytas oh I mean she
does huge all kinds of trolling stuff
basically in my opinion like she got a
couple years ago came out into the shoes
of voting for Mitt Romney and I got a
ton of hate and [ __ ] yeah and played it
beautifully I thought good all her [ __ ]
she does she just she just troll is
basically I see the video saying like do
dogs have brains and everyone talked to
Matt [ __ ] calling her stupid but then
it's like ah but it's all these views
you know yeah that big blonde girl yeah
the bbw bright yeah I saw that out I was
like people actually get mad and believe
her because you could totally right so
she plays that dumb blonde
I see and she plays it up hard she knows
exactly what she's doing I did a vine
with her with her boyfriend long time
ago which boy for an old guy
you know the new guy yeah yeah before
they were together like me all eyes he's
like 60 years old
well no no he calls himself the old guy
cuz he's literally like 40-something
well yeah he came up with all like the
vine crew that turns at YouTube he's
like one of batchest friends and all
them yeah yeah but yeah oh yeah that's
cool
that's funny people actually believe it
all the time do they believe everything
and then she did her and the old guy
they broke up and it became like this
huge viral sensation that they broke up
Jason s know his name is called that oh
the old guy okay not gone he's not
blowing him up he's just no I know his
name is old guy in the vlog Oh like that
is like Campbell or something other [ __ ]
be this guy's name I just forgot cuz
I've heard of the name Jason national
bunch right you know trash guys and yeah
wag did ya whack dude the guy who looks
like he pours whiskey right into his
face yeah so apparently Ariana Grande
now says that she's using music as a
coping mechanism like every musician
ever wait but she didn't do it before
like a musician right so she's drinking
and recording your album but now she's
just gonna record her album without so
now she's already recorded the album so
she's working on another album that
sober
she says she's 60% championship so maybe
% music I wonder how much she's drinking
like cuz you know how some people say
they drink a lot and then you see how
much they drink you're like that's not
well look you also got to remember she's
tiny so one shot is probably like takes
up 60% of her [ __ ] already like floors
she probably weighed as much as this
[ __ ] banana yeah you give Bart some
liquor it's the same [ __ ] I'm drinking
not to help me you know to cope with my
pain is through music but that's like
every musician ever yeah so that's their
outlet is that her new thing now that
she wasn't doing that before was
something that's a good point but you
know what you know what I feel like
that's gonna like that's silly I feel
like that whole thought of you know I'm
going through pain so I need a drink
it's kind of like [ __ ] you learn from
the movie yeah
cuz it's like okay I drink just cuz like
I've been drinking just have fun right
but I feel like the whole thought of I
had a long day man I need a drink
I need to go to the bar is something I
learned from just watching TV shows what
do you do what do you do when you have
like a long day or like I jack off they
yell in the shower like you're doing
Tarzan yell in our day today Jackie not
does make you feel better though smells
like soap and bleach in the bathroom
again
oh no
fact like dag off and like I don't know
um I'll take a bath usually about a
really rough day that's a good night
really I like a nice bath to be honest
we haven't taken a bath in a
[ __ ] five year period you and I
could barely fit in one exactly that's
exactly what it is when I take a [ __ ]
bath dude it looks like I'm being
punished would you guys take baths it's
just your butt all the way to your neck
and your [ __ ] legs are up like that
in two inches of one versus I would take
a bath like with a girlfriend or
something she's just like this is what
happens usually hers never party pepper
like a 260-pound member for and taking a
bath with a woman it's like she would
freeze to death I don't have room no and
then I'm called to you guys filling up
the water like 10% and then getting in
and it goes to the top yeah pretty much
not breathe not me bro me and my chick
it's like we're gonna blew in a pool you
get in she's like wow there's even less
water this is great yeah a nice a nice
hot bath is nice for me it's kind of
like a like a full body hug you know me
I like hot bath do you like hot
scorching like that kind of bath I don't
like scorching as hot as my chick likes
it but I like I like I like it you gotta
when you get in I gotta ease your way
into it Disney cartoon
[Laughter]
I love that where he's like some pepper
in himself yeah like he's famous ooh
yeah I want it to boil me yeah that's my
fear if it doesn't turn red then it's
not a good path
you guys just go right in though just
bright and you I do that for cold for
like cold things there like a cold pool
or whatever like I just jump in I don't
do that well yeah you got to do that
yeah I [ __ ] up cuz we had bunch of my
buds when I was in like middle school we
were all at his place and the jacuzzi
was like almost frozen because it was
cold outside I was like I'm Virginia I'm
like Riverside it was a cold it was a
cold winter okay and so yeah it was like
you know 40 degrees or some [ __ ] outside
and so the water was like you know ten
degrees above freezing really so we we
all challenged ourselves to go in and
try to last as long as we can like the
biggest man last the longest so some
young people [ __ ] right there
yeah dude so I [ __ ] I wanted you to
win because I'm competitive as hell and
I feel like I'm playing a game of Smash
Brothers I'm just like let's [ __ ] go
then you welcome to the hospital than
what happened no to this day when I try
to go into cold water now I have to like
ease my way in because I'm like you won
though right you did that cheers okay i
won
oh yeah but I lost in the long run dude
it wasn't worth it he has like frostbite
you got to get two toes amputated don't
you want you only drink lukewarm water
and Alan [ __ ] and that friend I don't
even talk to him in yeah [ __ ] that guy
remember cuz he's a loser I don't talk
to losers yeah Iranians with people who
win [ __ ] you Ernie
[Music]